Alexa and Carlos penny Vega dish on
marriage and Parenthood the key to a
successful marriage is sacrifice ET sat
down with the stars of Hallmark's new
holiday flick enchanted Christmas and
maybe a Christmas dance and they opened
up about their recent move from Los
Angeles to Maui with their 11 month-old
baby boy Oshin what initiated that move
me yeah I was public two years trying to
convince her to move and that's why she
had the baby she realized the importance
of having a good community and I just
rather raised a little island baby and
will be outdoors not hooked to the phone
the importance for us is family first so
we've really wanted to kind of get off
the grid a little bit your vlog is
literally the best thing on the internet
you guys really don't hold back at all
you're very candid you talk about all
these things you're going through would
you ever do a reality show you know what
we've gone back and forth on this just
because we've been approached by people
to do one and it's hard I feel like we
already kind of do one but in our own
way and in our control you know reality
nowadays is not really reality it's so
contrived they give you scenarios and
like okay we have to have drama so we're
gonna create a little friction here and
I'm like wait a minute we're married
there's already drama you don't need to
create anything but I you know it just
would really depend on the circumstance
the couple also revealed the key to
making a marriage last in Hollywood our
big thing is that we go everywhere
together so if he's on a project I won't
take a project if I'm on a project he
won't take one so we're literally
together as a family all the time we do
miss out on some really great
opportunities because of that but I
think that with any marriage the key to
a successful marriage is sacrifice you
know both parties have to sacrifice them
if it means missing out on a really
great TV show I love you and I thank you
so much
it's okay I didn't want it anyway how
has Parenthood changed you guys I feel
so much more love now I became become so
much more emotional about things and I
have a deeper connection with Carlos
just because of ocean having a kid just
heightens everything for you and you
appreciate life a lot more it takes it
from love to like love I can't explain
it
[Music]
you